欢迎收听深红投资
那我们上一集呢
俊仁杰跟我们讲到他的投资历史
那这一集我们来问一些问题
你有没有最推的三本书
最推的有作手
这个我蛮喜欢这本书的
这蛮有名的
他是不是
是幽灵的礼物
不是不是
应该是不同人
OKOK
是受江
一个作者
大陆的作者
为什么对
因为他大概是把
一个成功的交易员
中间的心路写类识
都把它写进去了
重点是他这本书
就是你每次
你到每一个阶段去看这本书
都会有看到不一样的东西
你一开始看可能不懂
但是你过了一阵子再去看
你有得到不同的体悟
OK 作手
对
他是比较是讲一些心路历程
跟心理层面的东西这样
那有没有第二本
第二本就是CIS
这本就更有名了
我会推荐的这本书的原因是
真正会赚钱
或是成交量那么大的人
那你看到外面有书的
都是成交量
基本上都是很小
或是根本没赚钱的
那这本书是
它是日本
真的是很厉害的一个人
那你变成第一次
可以去窥看他这些
就是真正的大户
在想什么
跟他的思维是怎样
所以我蛮推这本书的
所以像我自己在做
比较短线的几天的
这种波段
我们也都是用
类似这样的方法
所以你其实当冲里面
他的这个管理
也是你觉得很有共鸣
对啊
他蛮多在强调强势谷的嘛
当冲也是挑强势谷在做
对我来说技巧还好
而是第一次可以看到
成交量那么大的人
他的心路历程
包括他说他那个散崩嘛
散崩他做了几秒的判断
这是一般台湾人书会写的
那我好奇问一下
所以你大部分做顺势
可是你会不会偶尔做逆势啊
当冲吗
对啊
还是会
其实挡住啊之类的
不要说挡住了
就是买比较多
买比较多
打开啊
国家自然就会止跌了
好
好 没错
那第三本书
第三本书
我推荐一个是
90天赚900万
这本书就是比较冷门了
一个高雄的
一个科大的林教授写的书
这本书很薄
但是它里面写的蛮不错的
它主要也是讲心理层面
因为它就是一个教授
自己去交易的例子嘛
那它一开始也是赔钱
然后后来到90天
可以赚了900万
它在之中发现了
其实交易最重要的是心态
那这是我第一本
接触到心态的书
在此之前可能都是
比较看一些技术面
或是就算是机门面也好
或是一些各种外面的书籍
但是这本书
是我第一本
接触到心理的书籍
后来看完之后
发现对我帮助很大
才从这本之后
才开始看各种的交易心理这样
那也是因为这样
才发现
其实最重要
交易最重要的是
你的心态的问题
那这本书大概
初学的所有的心态问题
这本书都有解答
你可不可以举个一些例子
因为它是比较偏初学的心态
但是就包括损失回避
那以这个来说就是
新手阶段一定是
你赚钱跑很快
那赔钱你舍不得砍
那这就是所谓的损失回避
就是你不希望你是赔钱的
你希望你每天的
以时间都是赚钱的
那你就会变成
永远都是大赔小赚
因为你赔钱你就想说凹单
那你赚钱你一下就停利了
那搞不好你可以赚100%
就后来只赚了5%
这些都是一开始
交易会遇到的问题
那这本书上面都有写一些答案
OK
对所以蛮推荐的
所以你看得出来
反正他就是少数
虽然是教授
可是他又是一个实战的人
我当下看的时候
因为那时候是每一本书都看
但是那时候看的时候就觉得
这本书好像是真的有帮助的
但是以现在来看的话
这本书就是真正是
有真正交易的人写的书
外面的书
但是你看完之后就觉得
哇当初很好赚
不就是一个图
这边买进这边卖出
这边买进卖出
那这本书是你看完之后
就会知道
当初是很痛苦的对那我们来问一下你每天的作息好了因为像我们自己的话我们是波段交易者我们晚上其实会做很多功课不会是基本面或看筹码
那像你如果只有当冲的话
那你
我早上就交易嘛
那下午基本上
你今天起来
大概七点
OK
你会吃早餐吗
盘装大爷吃早餐
因为像MGK说他非常规律
他好像都固定会在
八点五十分大便吧
他说的
我其实七点起床
大概八点开始
看一些前一晚
欧美股市发生的事情
然后还有看一些新闻
你是自己的操板室
对
我现在有一个办公室
那就交易
我不会打GAN
我知道我会在盘中打游戏
但是我如果盘中真的没破洞
我就是休息了
那个手术
你有算过吗
一秒钟可以9下多
大概一下100ms左右
这用怎么记的
你就点一个不会成交的价格
你看你一秒钟
因为你会有看盘软体
你就会知道
你一秒钟可以点几下
你就一直按
你就可以去用看板软体的时间来抓
你这一秒钟是大概几下这样
可是这样一直按不会酸吗
会酸啊
所以滑鼠很重要
所以我那时候也是按到
晚睡到正后群
每次交易完都会整只手麻掉
或是有时候是真的是
波动很大的时候
你会按到麻掉
你要手起来甩
不然你手没办法维持一样的速度
所以就会按一按甩一甩
再继续按这样
没想过用程式
因为你那个量
很多人会怀疑是程式
没有就是纯手动
疫苗
你说一下
1minisecond
那所以打完
不是是100minisecond
一下1minisecond
那中午会吃饭吗
就是收盘之后吃
后面呢
下午大概就休息到
大概傍晚吧
吃完晚餐之后
大概六七点
就开始做一些功课这样
然后就知道睡前
做功课做那么久
这段期间
包括我看书
我到现在还是会去看人家的书
对我来说也是算做功课
然后是去思考
你今天早上检讨
对我来说也是做功课
所以我做功课
大概就是看书
然后看有没有新的想法
然后跟早上的交易的检讨
其实因为检讨
其实就很花时间
因为你之前在你FB上贴文
你那个委托
我看天都到万了
超过
对吧
那这怎么检讨
我举例像菲比斯
对
他说他每一笔
他都用Excel
就是这一条做好为什么
做不好为什么
他就这样
因为我们进出
实在是太频繁了
所以没有办法这样做
所以只能是大概的检讨
因为你真的是有一两万笔
那一两万笔的时候
你不可能每一笔去做检讨
而是你要去检讨
例如这一段期间
你做了什么事情
例如你这十分钟就是买进
你不用去检讨每一笔
那你检讨你会写下来吗
然后存起来变成
会会会
我也会把它印下来这样
有时候把它走势图印下来
所以你现在还是到了凌晨
那个因为你不是升
最近升
你会吗
对
那你是什么时候陪
休校午
校午到就是开始做研究之前
很累
很累啊
不过比较累
好
那继续问一下
那你在这个过程中
你进步的方法是什么
勤奋的检讨
勤奋的去思考
你到底为什么赔钱
其实这样就会进步了
这是我很相信的事情
像很多人都会私讯我说
你要怎么去练习
或是干嘛
其实我都会说
你就是做交易就对了
你只要把钱在里面输赢
你赔就算赔100块
你只要认真
连100块的原因都找得出来
你长久下来
你赔钱的情况都遇过了
你就会赚钱了
但是大部分人都做不到这件事情
就是我早上点一点就可以赚钱
那我点一点也可以赚钱
点完之后就真的点完了
那赔钱也没有去找出它的原因来
这就是我看到大家的问题
大概是这样
蛮难的
因为有时候我会不知道是不是过度检讨
就是说我这笔是赔的没有错
可是所以我要怎么正确归因说
所以是这个原因
所以是
没有一定会赔钱
我的意思是你要
就算是一定赔钱的东西
你也要去知道
没关系
这个就是我本来就该赔的钱
但是有些人是本来就该赔
跟本来不该赔
連這個事情都區分不出來
如果你賠錢
然後你檢討完
這筆錢本來就該賠
那你反而心情會很好你好像真的損失掉了但是你會想這筆錢我本來就是因為我之前用做這個动作我赚了很多钱但是这个动作本来就不是胜率百分之百所以我赔了一点钱
那也没关系
那你现在怎么测试你的新策略
想必因为你做这么多年下来
你也看了很多这个事况的改变
那你一定有太久换新吗
开发新策略
或是在思考新策略的时候
当然是最简单
就是用肉眼去做回撤
当然是也可以量化
如果我可以量化
我都一定会量化
但是如果没办法量化做回测的话
那你就是用
先用肉眼去验证
你肉眼去验证了一段期间之后
你发现是OK的
你当然就用金钱去做验证了
不过我其实所有的策略
基本上都是直接从金钱做验证了
因为接下来就会告诉你
这次策略到底是可以赚钱
还是要替换掉的
跟很多人程式交易是一样的意思
只是程式交易可能前面focus
在前面的量化去做回测
可能是50%
然后后面上下之后的表现是50%
去做替换这样
但是我可能是前面只有10%
然后后面90%
就是用金钱去做验证
赔钱你找不到原因
或是这个策略
根本就是一个错误的策略
那你就会把它替换掉了
我记得你砸很多钱
在测试
或者是弄新的策略
因为我现在找的策略
像我开发新策略
我一定不会找一个
没办法放大的策略
我一定会找一个
我可以把我的资金
再把一部分移过去
那策略的为那量
一定是要够的
那这种比较大型的策略
那用你的金钱去做验证
一定也是蛮痛的
好的
反正
比如说我们现在下半年就开始
当初变得不好做嘛
对
你会开始就想
有没有什么其他的方法
一直在测
应该是说
也交易十年
这十年已经
练了很多方法了
就像现在我把
选择权卖方的比重
已经拉高了
那就是去做
卖方当初的比重拉高
反而现在
要想到一个新的商品
或策略
已经是比较难的一件事情了
等于是你手上的好几个武器
你会
这个现在不好用
你就换这个试试看
对对对
那其实我们超然是在做
也有点像
手上有好几种招式
反正就用用看
用用看这样子
然后用顺就用多一点
对
那你11年的交易的历程里面
你有没有那种
很低潮很低潮的时候
那你是怎么去度过
现在每天都蛮低潮的
现在就蛮低潮的
低潮就是有分
像我一开始的时候
可能是找不到方法的低潮
那中间有些是
赔很多钱的低潮
现在是可能是
赚不到钱的低潮
那遇到低潮的时候
这句话我就是觉得
对我来说是最重要的话
就是交易的是交易解决
你交易低潮
你就是想办法用
看你是
就是包括我说的
你找出新方法
或是看一下
你到底为什么赔钱
去结束你的低潮
我就是继续检讨
赚钱心情就好了
就是像
没有就是低潮的话
就是你就是一直检讨
对我来说
我的输押管道就是检讨
我就是要把原因找出来
专注专注
对
好
那你现在因为
经历过这一年多的
大多头以后
也赚了好大一笔钱了
那你会将你的资产放在非股票吗
我本身就对那个不动产
就是土地啊房子
所以本身也有在投资这方面
哪方面的
像前阵子有去投标法牌屋
明夏也有买一些土地这样
那你不会觉得是两个世界吗
一个流动性跟频率超快
然后一个很慢
我那边也没有说做得多好
所以那个可能要请人家来分享比较好
好
那你有没有给一些
本金不足的年轻人一些建议
大家都把一定都是
从小资金开始打起的嘛
所以亏损就算是几十块好了
或是几百块
你还是要把这原因找出来
不能因为你的薪水可能是五万
那你在那边股票市场
赔个一百块
你会觉得顶多
我赔掉一个便当钱而已
那你这一百块的原因不知道
那你的基本工就不确实
就像我那时候
友达买九千块
那我说那苏宁
是一天是几十块在跑的
但是你这几十块
你如果花很多时间去看
那个价值会是很多钱
你未来可能几百万的时候
就不用遇到这个状况了
其实我觉得好像成功的道理都差不多其实就是很专注的一直检讨你不能放过细节对啊就是现在我看到很多人很多像FB很多人在po一些他的对账单但是他可能就po了对账单
但是没有去思考每一笔
因为他可能一天出赢就200块
我今天赌输了200块
或是我今天赚了1000块
我很开心
我多了好几个便当
但是你赚1000块
如果你把那1000块的细节拿出来检讨
那未来的价值就不会只1000块了
那我以前没有问过你
就是说当冲这两个字啊
就是对某一些长辈来讲
它是比较负面的词
就是他觉得年轻人
怎么可以在这边赌博
不去好好工作
那你们有什么
对我来说一个工作
就是你花时间
就会得到回报的工作
那为什么他们这些老一辈
会这样思考
就是因为他们那时候
根本就是赌博
没有花时间
就像有些人德州布克
他们研究很好之后
德州布克是他们谋生的管道
他们可以稳定的赚钱
那德州布克对他们来说
不是赌博啊
但是德州布克对我来说
就是赌博
因为我赚不了钱
那我也没有花时间
在研究德州扑克
那就不能因为这样去
断定一个东西
是不是赌博不赌博
每个行业都会
做得很好的人
会讲这些话
通常是这个行业的失败者
那这种失败者的话
就不用听太多
老一辈就是
自己有刻板印象
那可是我们要怎么去
取得一个平衡
给一些年轻人建议
就是说假设他
说全家好帅
赚这么多钱
如果他产生了一种
他不想上班了
或是他现在就是
心思不在工作上
他就把手机放在桌子下
上班时间一直按按按
你会怎么去劝这种
你身边有这种朋友吗
就很简单
假设你在台积电工作
你可以边在台积电工作
同时又领鸿海的薪水吗
那不行嘛
那为什么你觉得
你可以做一个工作
然后同时间去领另外一份薪水
因为对我们来说
股市就是一个工作
那你怎么觉得
你可以边上一个班
轻松去赚取另外一边的薪水的钱
好
就是反正还是要专注啦
不要说太狠
好
那现阶段投资
做这个短线的交易
那除了赚钱以外呢
对你来说
你有没有什么其他的
想要追求的人生意义跟使命吗
没有
因为我钱赚的还不够多
所以我还没遇到这个问题
好好好
所以就还年轻
养家活口
对对对
好好好
那最后你有没有给这个听众
一些建议
一些体会
交易就是跟所有事情一样
你只要花时间
然后肯努力
然后非常的认真去看待这件事情的话
一定可以赚到的钱
OK 所以你觉得这个短线交易
比较没有天分的问题
我就没有天分的人
所以我花了很多时间
对我来说
就是像我现在可能一天是交易五小时
研究六小时加起来十一小时
那我之前可能是交易加研究的时间
一天十七小时
然后我都会跟一些想跟我学的
会说你一天只要花十七小时
做了这样做十年还没办法赚钱的话
我养你
讲成这样
对 我会这样讲
但是你前提就是你要十七小时
而且其实我身边也是
那种笔记都是很多本的
就是非常多本的笔记
非常多的检讨
你这样做了几万页的检讨
都还没办法赚到钱
我就觉得不太可能
对
你这样讲还蛮励志的
因为很多人会觉得
这个是不是
我没这个天分
没这个sense
没有我也没有天分
对我身边的很多成功的教育员
都不是因为天分这两个字
好那我们谢谢
俊仁杰这两集
为我们带来这些分享
那太太有要讲什么吗
你应该是今天
你今天是第一次听
杰哥讲这些故事吧
没有
我平常在家里很常讲
是哦
所以会分享这个投资
会啊会啊
他每天都说做很差
你们都这样
我今天
他说要吃土了
叫我绳子点花
洗烂
每次在群组里
都洗烂洗烂
结果
后对张单靠腰
这叫洗烂
好啦
那就这样
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive